No.
Hypothetically,
it's an attitude of skepticism,
irony towards rejection of grand narratives,
ideologies and universalism.
Critique,
criticize this objective,
notions of reason,
human nature,
social progress,
absolute truth in objective reality.
It's predicated on the idea that the reason that you categorize,
especially the reason that you categorize is to marginalize you.
Categorize to marginalized,
to obtain power.
Power is pretty much all there is.
Um,
there's other elements of postmodernism.
One of them is that human nature is merely a social construct.
See,
the reason for that as far as I'm concerned,
and this is a postmodern critique as well,
I'm going to move the center to the margin and the margin to the centers.
Why would you think that human nature is only a social construct?
Well,
here's why.
It's because that means you could construct it any way you want to.
That was a very common idea among this among the communists.
That's why my wanted to wipe out Chinese history.
That's why the red guard went around in China,
tried to destroy everything,
every element of China's history prior to approximately 1960 at that great
culture,
thousands and thousands of years old as well.
So you could bring in the new man.
But what does the new man,
well it was whatever slave mile happened to fantasize about or it was the
utopian person.
You take your pick.
But like I said,
if you take a look at the corpses,
you can pretty much figure out which of those two it was.
So what's up with these people?
These deconstructionists sees postmodernists.
What are they up to exactly?
Well,
here's the first thing
they came about pretty much when Marxism was no longer credible,
no longer tenable as an intellectual,
a set of intellectual propositions.
Now,
if you are a French intellectual,
you had to have a lot of corpses piled at your feet before you were willing to
think that you were wrong.
So here's an example.
I don't remember his name.
He was the architect of the killing fields in Cambodia,
wasn't Pol Pot.
It was one of his advisors.
Unfortunately,
I can't remember his name.
He took his phd at the Sorbonne
and he developed the thesis in the Sorbonne Would Marxists thesis that the
cities were parasites on,
on the land.
You know,
it's an extension of the whole bourgeoisie proletarian thing.
The cities were full of bourgeois types,
educated and educated parasites essentially who were doing nothing but stealing
what was rightly the farmers.
So when he came back Cambodia,
he put that into action and empty Delta cities and put all the intellectuals in
the city dwellers either to death or to work,
which generally resulted in death and killed about one sixth to one quarter of
the population.
But he got his phd from the Sorbonne.
Okay.
That's a good story because that's exactly how complicit the western leftist
intellectuals were in facilitating the horrors of the 20th century.
And it's not like we've learned anything since then.
Quite the contrary,
we just gone underground and that's what I see.
That's what I see when I see postmodernism.
So what happened was,
despite the affinity Western intellectuals for Marxism,
maybe because they weren't paid as much as bankers,
let's say,
if we're being cynical about it,
because I've often thought that if you paid sociologists as much as investment
bankers,
they'd be capitalist very rapidly.
Well,
which is also to say that you may underpay intellectuals at your peril and you
know that's actually dangerous because one of the things that's happening is
that as the universities have become corporatized and corrupted in a variety of
ways,
more and more of the professors or adjuncts,
right?
Think it's up to 30 40 50% something like that.
Now they've got no tenure,
they've got no job security,
and they're paid like $24,000 a year.
It's not a good idea to radicalize the people that are teaching your children.
But anyways,
okay,
by the end of the sixties so much data on the catastrophic failures of communism
had accrued that even the most intransigent of French intellectuals had to admit
that the Jig was up.
Okay.
But that's a problem because that's the whole ideology,
right?
That's the whole raise on debt.
But he says in his terrible Alberta French,
you're going to just give that up.
What are you gonna do after that?
Well,
what happened was postmodernism was invented.
And so it's a slight of hand as far as I can tell.
So,
and with postmodernism identity politics,
and so the postmodern transformation is,
well,
we were a little wrong with the working class thing.
It turns out that Communists killed them all.
And capitalists make them all rich.
And that's actually exactly the opposite of what we predicted.
But maybe there's still a way this could be salvaged.
How about if we,
we don't say working class capitalists,
we say oppressor,
oppressed.
Well,
just,
well,
just trends transform the terminology a bit and we'll start thinking about all
the other ways that people are oppressed and then,
and all the other ways that people are oppressors.
And then we can play the same damn game under a new guys.
And now look,
the postmodernists were Marxists.
So let's make no mistake about that.
Derrida himself said that postmodernism was a transformation of Marxism.
I'm not making this up.
The question is,
why?
Well because you could say what postmodernism is a valid philosophical school
and we'll get into that for a minute and they make some valid claims.
One of them,
for example,
this is a central postmodernist claim,
is that there's an infinite number of ways of interpreting the world and that
actually turns out to be technically correct.
Part of the reason that we've had a very difficult time building robots,
AI robots that can operate in the real world,
is because perceiving the real world turns out to be so difficult that we really
can't figure out how human beings do it cause it is susceptible to an infinite
number of interpretations.
So that's actually correct.
Now,
I'm not going to give the postmodernists a tremendous amount of credit for
discovering that because it was discovered simultaneously and about five
disciplines at pretty much the same time.
But you give the devil his due.